[Music]
i believe that the way you look up
somebody on instagram or you google them
now
in seven years you're gonna meet
somebody in real life and you're gonna
go look at
their public wallet
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
gary welcome to the nifty show it's
great to see you trev and joel it's a
real pleasure thank you so much
are you eating nuts there uh grapes okay
so that's maybe going nuts so you know
you're a little late i know you want to
buy the jets but as you can see from the
photo i pulled it up
i bought them yep they're mine i didn't
i didn't realize garbage pail kids and
street fighter
could be so profitable it's amazing what
nfts will do well you're about to find
out because you are getting ready to
launch
your first nft collection that you have
called
v friends tell us about them
10 255 tokens a little head nod to
crypto punks in some way but a little
bit a little a little different number
um when you know
in 27 in 2016 when did ethereum come out
you know 2015 15. yeah that makes sense
so 15 probably south by 15 but i don't
know the timing definitely then by 16.
an incredible uh friend of mine by the
name of aaron battalion
who is the cto of living social
groupon's biggest competitor time
rea has gone on to become a big you know
silicon valley technologist vc
brilliant guy tech tech tech boy
set you know we're sitting in a jam
session at south by and really broke
down ethereum for me because the year
before
that whole crew that would get together
we all bought bitcoin
and so you know you're starting to get
into that stuff you're starting to like
learn it and so
17 was when i really was looking at eth
and then
you know other blockchain stuff for
hearing about
and then and and and basically
when i understood that you could put
contracts uh
that that's that was like fascinating to
me right like you can put a lease on it
contracts contracts fine fast forward um
to you know you've hit me up joe we have
a great relationship with
our web 2.0 days and like i'm aware of
like wax and ethereum and seeing stuff
i invested in a company called roll in
vayner rc several years ago for like
individual coins personal brand like you
can imagine with all the stuff
and then the garage saling and the
collectible you can imagine but it's all
floating in east or out there for me as
i'm
you know navigating my life um very very
similar for me
to web 2.0 social media right like
watched fredster watched myspace
you know doing my wine thing and i'm
like this thing feels different right
and neil
look you know these blogs waxy.org and
jason kotke and the neil dash and like
hmm this techcrunch thing slash dot
you know you know and i'm like
there's something brewing and and what i
for me
i'm you know a pop culture
retailer businessman so for me i'm
always thinking like when's it going to
be ready for prime time
even sports cards a year i looked at and
that was something i very much
understood
it was like okay now i'll talk because
you've come back in a big way like
sports cards are just blown up
so for me it was really this winter
when i you know for you know april
through september was incredible
hardcore navigation of a thousand person
company a lot of fear with coveted
layoffs than hiring like just you know
gnarly kind of like 15-hour day life
just trying to make sure everyone's
healthy and safe and the business is
okay
and you know you kind of almost need
like a distraction when you get out of
like a eight month
you know like you know when you're a
captain it's an eight-month storm
and you finally get to come where waters
you're like let me go get a beer
and like and that beer for me was was
nfts
i was like i need some let me you know
this has been going on
let me dig in here a little bit deeper
and um
and that thing that happens in my life
where i'm like oh
we're okay it's 11 45 p.m
it's not 6 30 it's not 2 30. this is
getting close
let me get my [ __ ] together because i
like being involved in consumer stuff i
like when things are ready and
but i also don't want to say [ __ ] and i
also want you know this is the weirdest
one because the last two things web one
web two for me
nobody knew who the [ __ ] i was i had no
audience nothing
so in general i like doing homework this
was even more dangerous
and i'll continue to do that on podcasts
like this i'm like look i don't know
what that means or like
you know like i'm not there yet or you
know like all these things that
everybody has to do when they go through
their journey
you know there's so many new chains
there's so much going on
you know i decided to do v-friends on
ethereum
so there's all those dynamics of level
two and gas and all the things that
people
take shots at ethereum for which i'm
empathetic and i understand why
there's you know incredibly cool stuff
going on on other
another chains i want to understand it
all a mutable this for level two
wax with you joel what you guys are
doing like
polka dots solano cardano like you know
you're just kind of looking at it all
for me though much like web 1 and web 2
i didn't want to learn ruby on rails
right
i didn't i didn't want to learn how
amazon services worked
and going way back i wasn't learning how
to code in asp
for wine library's first site i didn't
care how we
had us you know i wanted to be dangerous
enough so i wasn't an
idiot but you know for me this is a very
interesting time
because with this there's a almost a
requirement to get a little bit deeper
you know just the hair there's also
money being exchanged
in a very different way you know that
first time you connect
a meta mask and you buy something and
that 40 second delay happens i'm like
wait a minute we're you know like you
know i'm patrick one of the biggest
things i'm going to do this like the 24
hours before my launch here is probably
make 800 videos and go live and be like
okay
i'm aware that some of you gonna buy
something for the first time i'm telling
exactly the fear you're gonna have
for 49 seconds um so just trying to get
my [ __ ] together
you know uh and also
trying to um you know jumping into
different discords reading
you know i get so passionate that i
always worry that my excitement
is confused with thinking i know
so i've been very aggressive with my
words of like i'm in my journey i'll
talk about when i get comfortable with
something i'll talk about it
i understand why people buy things let's
start there
i may not understand every single
tni on underlining tech but i'm going to
listen and try to at least have
something i can hang with um but i
definitely understand why people buy
things
and how i understand how markets get
built and what becomes of them
and that's why i've been telling people
that 99 of the projects may not end up
being a great investment because i
understand supply and demand
but it's an incredible time to be alive
i can't believe we're here right like
it's like
you know after going to web 2.0 i didn't
know how long
if ever would it be before my juices in
my body felt like oh i want to stay up
at all hours of night and learn
and meet people and all you know and
this one's so fun right like everybody
i'm like
following or dm'ing with or discording
with they've got their [ __ ] favorite
nft as their as their avatar the
metaverse is brewing
you know all this stuff is going on and
for me
what a lot of people don't know is two
years ago i got
very far along the path of creating
uh toys that were called workplace
warriors
and what what you know joe you know this
about me i know you know this about me
i do read a lot all my comments not like
i did in
207 to 211 i have way less time
but i i read a lot and you know
i get a lot because of the way i
communicate and what i talk about a lot
of people that are like
hey thanks for the i just watched your
video at lunch my boss is such a dick
it made me feel better or this and that
and like to the point where
i was like wait a minute this is gonna
be cool i like business
so that's me but i also love collecting
that's me
and i love having a selfless and selfish
thing right the whole like right it
works and i was like you know what i
think i'm going to do a toy
nice little 30 toy this is my [ __ ] this
is what i like
people put an empathetic elephant on
their [ __ ]
you know on their desk and when their
boss is a dick and they look at it
they'll think of me that says [ __ ] you
and look
you know like i was like this is gonna
really be good so i really went down
that path heavily
molding the design [ __ ]
and then you know and then got busy and
then boom code you know it was one of
those things where i'll address this
in q1 and there's so much to do when
you're creating a thing like that the
supply chain
and all these things oh my god all this
physical [ __ ]
so you nailed it you knew exactly where
i was going so now
i'm deep i'm buying some punks i'm
learning
um i'm i'm looking at all the superhero
cool [ __ ] you're doing
joel look at i'm just looking i'm
looking i'm looking i'm looking i'm like
wait a minute
[ __ ] i'm gonna be able to do my thing on
this
because what what happened with me is
what happened with wine library tv i'm
like oh [ __ ] the internet's changing
the way i sell wine for my dad is
changing what do i do what do i do
oh this youtube thing's gonna be the
biggest of them all
no i know about wine it was so left
field i mean you probably remember julie
it was so left field everything was tech
dignation zay frank it was all tech and
then this guy in new jersey with a wine
store starts this show and it worked and
i don't know how to do things when i
think the world's changing without
throwing myself into it
right you play with the toys that's how
you learn
so like i'm like i'm gonna make my own
i'm gonna learn a ton of [ __ ] and guess
what i have
and one you know and you know the web 3
stuff is
is really intense and really fun and and
i'm learning and i'm enjoying it and
i'm just so happy to be a part of the
community and like
um and thank you for having me on the
show
it's such a friendly community one thing
i've noticed about the nft space is like
it seems like everyone's sort of
uplifting each other right they're
outside
they're cheering each other on outside
of the different chains a little bit of
that gets a little
you know kind of thing and outside of
like
crypto currencies versus nfts yeah
you're seeing incredible behavior
and rooting for um listen there's a lot
of money there's too much
money going on i think that that
is the probably the thing i'm most
worried about with social
you were actually just building brand
and relationship and reputation
which kind of like helped i you know i
don't think
i think it's going to be a little weird
here trav unfortunately like there's too
much money being
exchanged like i already seen it from a
lot of couple people like dm
they're like oh are you upset that other
things launched right before your thing
i'm like
no way first of all the things they were
referencing were from
ogogs and i was like you know who am i
to
second of all you know one of the things
i'll tell anybody who's listening this
is just more macro
anytime you think someone's taking
something out of you
you're completely confused about how the
world actually works
the world the world is fundamentally
abundant
like there's plenty of room to buy punks
and to buy
you know to buy cardboard heroes and to
buy by the way this is what's going on
with the art world and the collectable
world all my sports card friends are
like what the [ __ ] you know
why are you so focused on this like you
put in so much into sports cards i'm
like both
i'm like they're going to help each
other tops this project on wax is going
to help its
cardboard and vice versa i think the
world is
if you do good [ __ ] it will be just okay
don't blame
somebody else's success for your lack of
execution
absolutely so you're going all in uh we
did you know i knew when you started
drawing these characters you were going
somewhere with it i said we got to get
on we got to talk about it
um i i brought you up to speed on nfts
with my knowledge i told you about wax
you decided to go with ethereum you got
to do what you got to do
but let's talk about what you actually
are doing here because these v
friends these are not just picture nfts
that gary has drawn you have tapped into
one of what we think is the key use
cases for nfts
and that each one is tied to something
real world
correct to me where i was starting this
thank you for bringing me back joe
you've always been good at that
you know uh um i'm throwing a massive
conference
called v-con where every one of these
tokens
so this is actually since we're looking
at it this is how it breaks down there's
10
255 tokens 9 400 of them
as you can see our admission tokens they
come in different rarities as you can
see
um and those are to your point if you
scroll up joe if you don't mind
um if you click vcon at the tippy top
just for the visual
yep so what's it what's interesting
about this if you scroll
down um
so vcon is a conference i'm throwing
uh actually can you go to vcon dot co
i don't know if you can do a i can do
amazing things
because because i have the internet i
can't type though
because i have the internet at my no
that is not a v com
i got myself involved there yeah that's
it you were bragging on a little too
early like oh yeah i can do all the
whoops yeah
except go anywhere so every token all 10
255 are gonna be invited to v con
that's how you get in to me this is very
you'll see so many inspirations in my
past south by southwest
web summit tech country disrupt right
like you know all the things that shaped
me
i want to throw that conference with a
little bit of music and entertainment
and actually believe it or not it's
basically
all those things i mentioned with
coachella and rolling loud
with summer camp so one of the things
i'm very excited about you'll see it
as we go back to vcon um
it's some of the tokens i did are called
competition tokens
um which are like tokens to have
one-on-one access to play me and
ping-pong
and then checkers and all this other
stuff and you go back to scroll up
because this is
the smaller one why don't you go meet
the friends yep right there
yep um so if you scroll down right so
there's three
there's there's access tokens so let's
go back 9 400 to the conference
555 called gift goats you buy this token
you connect your wallet and put your
address and stick with me here trav
six times a year minimally six over
three years because all these tokens are
three year
things you know off chain tokens six
times a year
i send you surprise and delight gifts
mmm thank you joel so as you can imagine
what's really cool about this is once i
see what everybody pays for it
i take a step back and i'm starting to
reverse engineer for example
if the first gift i send is more than
people paid for the goddamn token
shit's gonna get really weird and this
is and i this was important to me for a
reason
if this just was my doodles i'd have no
control after the fact
unless i do what i'm up to which is i'm
going to spend the rest of my life
building this intellectual property
so i'm going to try to do cartoons and
backpacks and toys
and movies and streetwear brands so i'm
going to really
this is probably where my career is
going
this this is my now intellectual
property this is my
zelda this is my pokemon this is my
scooby-doo
and i'm going to see how far i could
take it and i think i'm very good at
building brand
and you know there's and so that's the
tokens and then there's 300 access
tokens which i think
you know it's funny i went back and
forth on doing this because i didn't
want really to be about me and my time
so much of this is about building up
characters that represent the things i
talk about
so that i'm not the front man of my
passions but
i did want to send a blueprint as the
project was evolving i was noticing a
lot more people coming out
that had audiences and doing very
[ __ ]
projects that i thought were money grabs
and i thought a lot of people gonna lose
a lot of money and then hurt the space
so i said you know what
i'm gonna put a blueprint of what i
think a lot of people are missing
in this project and that's what i think
with access tokens so with access tokens
you buy the token you get the
collectible you still get
in addition the conference but if you
scroll down joe in addition to this
being a ticket to the conference
for example there's 125 hangout hawks
all 125 people there are part of a
virtual hangout group with me that gets
together five times a year for 45
minutes
q a just with me then you see the
in-person ones dinner deer
lunch ladybug those are literally having
dinner together and what i'm excited
about
is i'm gonna work my tail off that if
somebody buys dinner
deer which is you know not going to be
inexpensive
but they're still going to own the next
two years rights
to that ticket so as you can imagine
they may be able to have dinner with me
and then if things go well
have an asset where they'll be able to
make a decision if they want to come
back next year
or put it up so it's important for me to
innovate on the multi-year
aspect and then and then you get into
the one-on-one access
again 85 of them are virtual
facetime characters so facetime fox is a
five minute face time with me again
multi-year thing
and then you get into the crazy one of
ones garage sailing yale literally go
garage sailing with me for four hours
on that episode of trash talk uh
podcast panther i think is a great one
uh you buy that token
i become a 45 minute guest on your
podcast so i can see a lot of people
seeing that as value a workout wolf
literally work out with me
and my trainer gone fishing fish
literally a four out
three hour i think fishing trip with me
i mean that's some quality
time um uh wine shopping spree woodchuck
which is really exciting um what's the
keynote koala do they get the keynote
with you or what
kinokawa is an unlimited token to every
public keynote i give in the world where
you get a vip ticket
and green room access meet and greet
prior to it
nice so what i'm hoping there for joel
is that somebody decides to treat me
like the grateful dead
and literally i see them at every city
in the world
vayner heads these kind of remind me of
sweet but sweet pickles back in the day
i remember these like yeah
yes remember yes yeah i remember these
they all had the nice they all have a
little good
feel good story behind them yeah they
broke it
actually i looked at it because i was
like wait a minute somebody said it to
me when i was like [ __ ] let me look at
it
they had a little bit of a mix there's
this is a little more positive
um uh so you know listen
there's also if you keep scrolling down
something i'm really proud of uh
uh the competition ones here
maybe my favorite one uno unicorn that's
literally
a four-person uno game three people will
buy that token
we're gonna have a four person uno so i
can draw four
uh and shouldn't it just be called a uno
corn i'm just
thinking on some real [ __ ] i'm
devastated right now
yeah right now right this second i'm
devastated that is so much better
god damn it look on the flip side i
think i did a good job with the bowling
boa
turning a pin into a snake i thought
that was creative
that's pretty creative thank you sir uh
finding
an animal that rhymes with ping pong was
tough but
there is a kalong bat out there thank
god so the ping pong kalong
um and then if you scroll down joel uh
five
scholarship access these are people
we're just gonna submit
i'm gonna give them five 45 minute
sessions with me 30 hours with vayner x
senior executives
and a paid uh internship to any vayner x
company
uh on the 10 royalties on the secondary
transactions
i'm keeping nine i'm giving one percent
to five charities i pick each year so
a lot of fun dynamics real fun big
ambitions project
[ __ ] going for it
yeah i think i think this is really cool
we've talked about this
joel and i you know over the time was
like you know this is nfts
and social tokens really i think the
combination between the two
give access to your favorite content
creators in a whole new way
right and you're taking that [ __ ] to the
next level with these nfts
being specific interactions which
nobody's done i've not seen anybody do
specific interactions this equals that
and you get to do this with me a lot of
people just here's a cool collectible
and enjoy it and have fun
you're actually diving in and you've
built a strategy and you set a blueprint
around
developing access to garyvee and
inspiring people on an ongoing basis i
think it's brilliant
thank you and then for me what's really
exciting trav
is i'm petrified like i i find people so
fascinating
people like oh short-term thing i'm like
are you out of your mind if this
fails i'm dead
like i'm spending the rest of my [ __ ]
life trying to make
some of these characters mean something
like why do i go to garage sales and buy
thundercats
because it eventually meant something
and thus that meant like it was worth
something versus
another piece of plastic at a garage
sale from something that nobody's ever
heard of
right why is why is it garbage pail kids
and street fighter and other cool things
on wax right like
because those meant something like now
now
if you notice i created something that
had a lot of real life value
in the first three years that gives me
time
to turn the tokens and the art into
meaningful collectible assets
i go and land a netflix cartoon deal
for four of these characters in a series
we're off to the races
if that series hits this is the pathway
to the jets this is it right here
i think so yeah well a couple things
first of all
um you're gonna kill it
or i should more aptly say you're gonna
crush it these are gonna sell out so
ridiculously fast
your head is going to swim it's gonna go
what the hell
just happened i have no question we see
a lot of these launches and we know
which properties you know are going to
resonate and which are not we usually
call them pretty good
sometimes we miss not going to mess with
this one and i'm not blowing smoke up
your ass
it's going to sell out super fast so you
don't have to be nervous about it
here's the thing you're talking about
this is the next part of your life it's
not just the brand
you are putting yourself so deeply into
delivering
after this purchase that yes it
literally is the next part of your life
you're going to be busy as hell you know
who was the happiest drock in my video
creative team
they're so pumped because they're like
oh this is [ __ ] gold
like we can finally make a vlog you're
so boring like you
you know you're set like fine but how
many episodes of dailyvee or weekly v
can people watch
of you being in meetings for 16 hours
like this is gonna be funny like
you're gonna they also know me when i
lose an uno
on some reverse card and then a draw
four
i'm gonna be pissed and it's gonna be
funny you know it's funny
the other part of this drill is and i
think again this is what's so fun to
talk to you guys because we come from
a time where we shared a lot of stages
and back rooms and
i'm so uniquely built for the way i
built this because i genuinely love
people
like to me i'm excited about meeting
barry
from indiana in a ping pong game or
having dinner with sarah and rick and
john like i mean this is like i'm
humbled by it i enjoy it i think a lot
of people
who are lucky enough that big audiences
actually don't like it they're a little
more introverted and i understand that
and maybe they'll do very different
versions of this or maybe just the
conference
or maybe just you know a hard good that
comes along with it
for me there is nothing that is more
valuable than someone's time and the
access to their brain their heart
and i'm uh and i'm hoping it inspires
people and i think you know i want to
buy
and you know i built this with the
intent of like some of the players that
play behind you
sir like i want to throw the football
with
zach wilson my new quarterback i'll pay
for that [ __ ] especially if i own the
token after it
like i'm built it you know i mean so
i'm you know cook you think about it
famous chefs authors it's not just about
influencers and celebrities if
somebody's the foremost expert of
beekeeping
and she puts out 50 coins tokens
nfts and and five of them are the
gold honey ones and those come with a
two-hour session with her of like really
doing it
that's meaningful if i could do it with
a music if a music producer put this out
and i want to be a music producer
and i get three hours in studio with him
or her
i mean this is really meaningful and i
think i think the other thing you have
to think about
one thing i did very late so i don't
know i didn't know as well as
i still am a little nervous because it's
dragging so
but as i started seeing demand building
a little bit more i'm like wait a minute
i started taking more tokens off that
i'm holding for myself
because i want to give away more to my
discord community
because you know all of a sudden you
know things can get expensive and
you know so you've got to think about
all that stuff and i've been enjoying
the strategy and the thinking of it
yeah what are the prices going to be are
these all going to be auctioned off or
so all dutch auction trap i was very
worried about
what i knew i would have is 30 40 50
people i haven't released the prices yet
joel
um but trap i knew there was like a
hundred people
that were smart enough to know this is
actually buying into me forever
and so they were gonna buy them all i
was very worried about that
i heard a couple things just like just
not like heard
in the in rumors i mean talking to
people and i could just see
i was like some of these whales will do
that stuff man they're gonna go out
there i had an extra problem
i have new whales that have never bought
anything that really know me and have
been really following me
and are like you know these are people
that are offering 100 million dollar
investment to vaynermedia
to have a small percentage of the
company because they believe in me so
much
and they can't they so a lot of people
are
so as soon as i saw them hovering i'm
like [ __ ] that i i don't need a headline
that says gary v sells playing tennis
with him for a million dollars i was
petrified
of that douchery so i capped it and i'm
doing a dutch auction
so starting price that goes down
one so it starts at a price and it goes
down
and it basically in essence becomes a
buy it now game right you kind of like
are playing the game of like
do you want to snipe it at this price or
not is somebody else going to come in
um so the floor on the majority of them
are 0.5 eth
which is obviously moving a lot since
this project started so
but for me i'm pouring it back into the
conference and into the gift goats
like if this does uncomfortably well
you know it means i'm going to throw the
best conference in the world
you know that you know i'm treating this
as an enterprise and as a real
corporation
that like when i look at workout wolf
right now joe's got that upright in the
forefront when i look at that right
i'm like i should probably build a 50
million dollar protein shake business
around him
like i'm capable of that you know people
are very confused by my
business vacuum they're so they're so
focused on gary b
the character in the last 10 years i
started rezzy
with ben leventhal the restaurant app
it sold for 200 million dollars to amex
i started empathy wines with two former
interns it sold for
close to nine figures to consolation
brands
vaynerx has eight companies underneath
it
i run it day to day um and
it's a global company doing north of 250
million dollars in revenue we just
opened up mexico city
my brother and i started a meaningful
sports agency
or a major player in ufc immediately you
know 40 and
plus nfl players so like i i
i'm excited because i know what i'm
going to do as the operator as gary
vaynerchuk the business operator against
the intellectual property of this
project
so that's nothing makes me happier than
that because
then i can really come through so
you were gonna launch on uh on my
birthday
thanks for that but uh that was the
single reason by the way i know
happy birthday thank you for whatever
you're 40 what are you 40 now
yeah stop it you you flatter her with
your words
57 there junior 57. i wish i look your
hair's better than mine i'm impressed
you work a lot harder um the the launch
is being pushed out
to what day in what time do you know
this i know this is airing on friday
i i promised that i wouldn't even put
this out because i don't want to
put anybody in a curious spot but i'm
early next week i'm feeling confident to
say that
okay so they need to definitely and i'm
definitely definitely giving everybody
now because of the way it's gone down
a full 24-hour notice and then i'll do
it
yeah you'll post on your twitter and
your discord i'll tell you what here's
here's what you need to do you know
whenever we do a sale we always buy
a little our own because we like to play
so i would say
buy at least one that gives you time
with yourself so you can have some time
off
oh i like that i like that
what happens to this i'm curious about
the mechanics on this it's like say i
buy one of the one of the things is one
of those three year deals where you get
a dinner with gary or whatever five
times a year or you there's only a
one-time use and you use it
what's the stops is it is it burnable
like once they
once they are using it they got to send
it to you then it gets burned
or how do you take it out of circulation
so somebody doesn't try to sell it again
to somebody else it's validated on
change
now how wait how are you doing that do
you know um
yeah so what what we did with um
i i to your point so jim and the team at
nft 42
have just been remarkable oh gee guys i
don't i
i don't want to miss especially publicly
miss explain it
but i'd love to jam with you guys
offline um i've i've had like four of my
other hardcore
nerd friends be like yep good so um
we're validating in that way and and
making sure that
it's also like piping to um um
to open c uh and anywhere else i'm
petrified of that part
uh trab of anybody being confused that's
probably
stood me up the longest what if somebody
gets confused that it no longer has the
access
right um we did that and we we've
encountered that because we sold
our nifty boxes a membership card and we
did a couple that were just good for a
month
says right on it november 2020 but
people were then selling them after and
somebody could buy something that has no
use what they have to do is they got to
send it to you
and then it's validated and you could
actually send them back a different
version one that's already been used
that way they no longer have that
version
to be able to sell i feel excellent i
feel incredibly comfortable
in what what they built but i also want
to make sure i speak to it
and obviously as we get closer here i
will have all those teas and eyes
crossed
i don't understood so are there any of
them that are just purely collectibles
or does
everything has function well no no
actually no
everything has function every single
token is a three-year ticket to
b-con everyone what three-year ticket to
v-con that's beautiful
yeah we gotta get it i got we gotta get
these dudes we gotta go we gotta go to
v-con
that is the thing that excites the [ __ ]
out of me because
wait you know think about this i care
about my reputation dearly
i definitely care about my community not
more than my reputation like you know
everyone cares about their reputation
the most
so for me what's really exciting is the
three-year thing if it was a one-year
thing
i couldn't do what i'm going to do for
my community i'm going to throw such an
un
i mean i'm putting oh i you know my poor
accountant
and my finance team they ran the numbers
they're they're very big numbers
at the prices that things are going
right and when
i said to them i'm like look can we talk
about you know tax write-offs for and
they were like for what i was like if if
this
company loses money they're like loses
money what are you talking about like
guys i'm not selling a doodle like you
read on
the newspaper i'm like i have i have
i have 555 people getting 18
meaningful gifts that's math and these
will be
these aren't going to be 40 gifts
there's going to be very expensive gifts
who the [ __ ] knows where these people
are gonna live i might have to ship
something to [ __ ] sri lanka who [ __ ]
you know like
so there's that second
this conference is gonna be bananas
i'm probably gonna have what 8 thousand
you know you guys probably know this
stuff better
i'm ten ten two five five seven thousand
eight thousand because obviously some
people have multiple you know
tokens and i need to throw something
that's insane
yeah because it's not gonna be cheap no
v-con 2022
has to be insane because if it does
and it is and it will be well then
everyone's gonna win
all the token holders get bombarded when
everybody sees what the [ __ ] i did and
well you know if you have some of the
biggest names in the world performing
if you have the greatest keynote
speeches those
those speakers are going to cost me
money like this is going to be i mean i
expect b-con to be a seven
figure production each year and i'm not
talking about one million
so like you know i'm not i'm scared it
might be an eight figure production
for the first one i need to blow it out
of the world
but even if it's a lost leader gary
you're building this
brand correct right and that that is
really the long game it's not like
you're going to suck because
because i am an extremely successful
author who has a lot of leverage who's a
free agent
after this book that i have coming out
and first my publisher harper is going
to be very interested
in my books because i'm a money maker
for them so when i say to them hey
remember when you signed me to that 10
book deal years ago and it really worked
out
let's let's have a conversation here i
want to come out with a kid's book which
i do by the way
but these characters and i want to teach
kids that empathy matters i
want to teach kids that compassion
matters but i also want to teach them
that accountability matters
and like some other things and the world
needs that man the world needs more
kindness we're more divided than ever
we got to teach these principles and i
think that i gary vee
am a good deliverer of information for
63 of people but you two know this
i'm not naive there's 30 of people who
think i'm
bad because i'm aggressive i'm a jersey
kid i curse
uh i have so much conviction they feel
like i'm a know-it-all or
just flexing or you know
entrepreneurship burnout and there's a
lot and
i and i'm empathetic to that i don't
think that those are bad people i think
why should they spend 15 hours really
understanding what i'm saying
we haven't had the luxury to really have
a conversation they don't know how
i act one-on-one so i i'm empathetic to
that i now have this whole universe of
characters to still let me put good
deposits into the world
for people who tune me out and i think
anybody
who's been parented as well as i have
who's grateful
who's happy i think all the happy
grateful people
have an obligation to put more good into
the world and
i do that and i take the heap for it as
gary vee
and and now i have patient panda
right to do that and i'm gonna do that
and i'm really proud of it i think it's
going to go well and
and i can do all my stuff right i can do
that part while also
my street wear sneakers hoodies
i can go do jv's with the best
streetwear brands in the world
and create that part and scratch that
itch
or my my toy collecting part i can do
that workplace warriors thing in a
different form now
and and you know because i was so
affected by toys
as a kid you know collectible toys and
so
i'm like i'm really and what about my
consumer package good stuff like
i look at workout wolf i just did it
right now that was the first time i
thought it right now in a spot i'm like
oh wait a minute
i could probably turn that into a
protein bar or something work out wolf
like
what like i'm gonna show the entire
bag of tricks and that's why i think the
people that get behind this
project have a dark course chance of
doing really well because if we all wake
up in 22 years
and the ip means a lot well then these
these nfts are going to have some
meaning well gary we appreciate you
coming on you uh you promised us
15 minutes and you've way over delivered
you have many words and
and i know that people are gonna they're
gonna enjoy it thank you brother you
mean a lot to me you guys grew up with
me and that's that the last thing that
felt like this to me
we were there we were there in those
conference rooms and those
conferences like we all remember
and that's what this is um
and i'm coming in at the same exact time
i came in in 07
and it was really starting to really
happen at 0-4-5 that second wave
this thing has been happening i've been
watching from afar you don't think i
noticed joe when you changed your
backdrop on twitter to like superhero
[ __ ] i was like whoa
i like that [ __ ] what you know like but
but i come in
there's a certain time when i like to
dance when it's a little bit more mature
because my head is not as technical i'm
consumer i'm more consumer
so i needed to be just a little bit more
mature i've got just enough danger
to understand it but i need it to be a
little further along
and and i think we're in that moment and
i think in 24 48 months
everyone imagine what it's going to be
like yes 24 to 48 months
when the masses are like okay the
water's
good come on in that's right we've not
seen anything
everybody understands this is actually
social media 4.0 meaning
everyone's public wallet right i keep
telling my friends i'm like social is
getting more private
and crypto's about to get more public
the public wallet
right when i saw rainbow right when i
saw the rainbow wallet i was like uh-huh
right like i believe that the way you
look up somebody on instagram or you
google them now
in seven years you're gonna meet
somebody in real life and you're gonna
go look at their
their public wallet you can see what
nfts are in there
just talking about i've always been
thinking about this as a long time like
why are some of these folks want to put
some of these photos and videos that
they're sharing
up on instagram when they could go
create an nft out of them
and and then have their fans buy them
with their social tokens right
they're going to do that yeah for sure i
didn't know that you did roll by the way
we
we actually have a token on tryroll we
have the hero token which is
currency for bad crypto and nifty show
yeah again it's funny i'm about to put
out a ton of content of me in 2017-18
breaking this [ __ ] down it's gonna be
fun for me right because i know i know i
listen that's why
when i started getting a little louder
in february march oh here we go this
[ __ ]
now this guy and i'm like i'm like it's
just the same old thing like
it you should have seen what happened in
madison avenue when i started my agency
years ago you know that's when i was
kind of segwaying from web 200 to
madison avenue
oh twitter boy that was one of the
headlines twitter boy thinks he can
do [ __ ] you know to me to me
when you don't hear the cheering meaning
for me
i don't care what when i all the things
i accomplish i know
that i'm just another human being and if
i get hit by a bus tomorrow
unfortunately
i'll get a nice at the point that i'm in
my career i'll get a nice
12 hours eight hours on twitter and
instagram
screenshots gary did this for me i've
done a lot of nice things behind the
scenes i'd like to think those stories
would get out
and then it'd be next friday
and 99.9 and at 100 more nines
we'll move on with their lives and a
small group of my family and my closest
friends will
linger but then that's it and so when
you don't think of yourself
as anything special
you don't hear the cheering it actually
makes you very strong against the booing
when people [ __ ] on me and plenty of
people have
mocked me after i launched befriends you
know they've got their different takes
you know i understand why but i'm not
devastated
or unable to deal because i can't hear
the cheering
and and the reason i'm saying this on
the way out right now is
there's a lot of incredible people
listening to this show because there's
no reason to listen to this show
think about who would listen to this
show you've got to be incredibly
progressive incredibly creative
incredibly
cool in my opinion and i want to
encourage them
because i feel like a lot of them have
pokemon
or transformers or raggedy ann
in them but they're scared to put it out
because they can't deal
with the negative feedback and i really
don't want them to because they can
change their lives and be happy and
putting out your art until
you you know everyone's like gary's art
[ __ ] like this is [ __ ] [ __ ] and i
was like you know
providence is such an important part of
this i drew every one of these
every one of these tokens comes with the
video
that of me actually drawing it wow
bonus you know so i'm really
like i understand i'm not [ __ ]
picasso but
they're not the worst i've always well i
can i can actually spot the nose on
yours i have a hard time with
picassos figuring out where they are so
anyway
i'm really happy to partner with the
community and really enjoy being on with
you guys and i wish you well
thanks gary appreciate you youtube
what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you